Ich habe eine Wohnung gekauft, mit dem
einzigen Grund, sie komplett zu
renovieren und daraus meine Traumwohnung zu bauen.
Nachdem ich euch gezeigt habe, wie ich sie
gekauft habe, die Community entschieden
hat, wie sie umgebaut werden soll und wir
im letzen Video alles rausgerissen haben,
geht es dieses Mal endlich
an den Wiederaufbau.
Das dachte ich zumindest, bis uns eine
böse Überraschung hinter einer der Wände
erwartet hat, die potenziell das gesamte
Projekt bis Dezember auf Eis legt.
Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß mit Folge vier!
Bevor wir aber anfangen konnten zu
arbeiten, mussten wir erst mal die ganze
Scheiße aus dem letzten Video beseitigen.
Wirklich Kubikmeter Abraum, also
Betonplatten aus den Wänden, Fliesen
aus dem Bad, Laminat vom Boden.
Ich wusste nicht, dass so viel Kram in
so einer kleinen Wohnung Platz findet.
Alles runter getragen, alles ins Auto
gepackt und diverseste Male
zum Wertstoffhof gefahren.
*Rapmusik*
Als das alles fertig war, konnten
wir endlich anfangen zu arbeiten.
Und vergesst nicht, den Kanal zu
abonnieren, um keins der folgenden Videos
aus diesem Projekt hier zu verpassen und
mich und das gesamte Projekt
hier kostenlos zu unterstützen.
Erst mal habe ich mich mit meinem Sanitär Betrieb
des Vertrauens, also Sanitär, Heizung,
Klima zusammengetan und wir haben
besprochen, was überhaupt
in diesem Bad möglich ist.
Das ist eben eine Bestands Wohnung und es
gibt nur begrenzte Möglichkeiten, an denen
wir uns irgendwie entlanghangeln mussten.
Das ganze war auf den ersten
Blick ziemlich ernüchternd.
Ich wollte unbedingt eine bodentiefe
Dusche im Bad und mir wurde gesagt Hey,
das ist mit ziemlicher Sicherheit nicht
möglich, weil wir nicht genug Gefälle in
die Wohnung bekommen, weil unterm Strich
potenziell Heizungsrohre liegen könnten.
Und so weiter.
Dazu wollte ich eigentlich unter Putz
kästen, also dass quasi das
Wasserreservoir für die Toilette
hinter der Wand verschwindet.
Und auch das war nicht die beste Lösung,
weil es deutlich mehr
Platz im Bad wegnimmt.
Als würde man eine andere Lösung nehmen.
Und ich dachte schon
jetzt habe ich angekündigt, dass das hier
alles so mega luxuriös wird und jetzt ist
es bau mäßig gar nicht möglich, so
wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Also erst mal angefangen, alle Wände
aufgemacht und geschaut,
was uns dahinter erwartet.
Ich habe tatkräftige
Unterstützung gefunden.
Ich habe natürlich den Riesenvorteil von
Reichweite und hat der Story gefragt und
es hat sich tatsächlich
eine Kölner Firma erbarmt.
Links dazu sind in der Videobeschreibung.
Aber wie gesagt, bei Wasser und bei
Elektrik ist es vielleicht ganz
schlau, sich Profis dazu zu holen.
Es geht um Dichtigkeit.
Es muss alles vernünftig, alle Schritte
müssen vernünftig gemacht werden.
Und wenn es da am Ende irgendwann Probleme
geben sollte, dann ist die
Scheiße richtig am Dampfen.
Also schaue ich als erstes mal ein
bisschen zu, helfe da, wo ich helfen kann
und erfreue mich einfach
daran, dass es weitergeht.
Und was ich zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch nicht
wusste Der Satz sollte sich
zu 100% bewahrheiten.
Und ich sage nur so viel Es war absolut
richtig, sich Profis dazu zu holen.
Aber erst mal Durchlauferhitzer aufbauen
und versuchen zu verstehen,
wo welche Leitung hergeht.
Die Wohnung ist von 1971, also über 50
Jahre alt und mit ziemlicher Sicherheit
sind die Leitungen genauso alt.
Oh, warte mal, auf diese Idee sind wir
auch gekommen, als wir
in der Wohnung standen.
Uns ist was ziemlich doofes aufgefallen,
um das jetzt besser begutachten zu können
und damit der Profi freie Sicht hat,
nehmen wir jetzt die Wand auch noch weg.
Das habe ich eigentlich gar nicht geplant
und wir hoffen mal, dass uns nichts zu
Schlimmes hinter der Wand erwartet.
mist
das  ist so ziemlich das Schlechteste,
was uns hätte erwarten können.
Das hier ist der ist Zustand.
Einmal die Ecke und ein bisschen
problematischer noch hinter der Muffe,
dahinter an und für sich kein Riesen ding.
Hier tropft es jetzt nicht aktiv raus, was
das Ganze aber problematisch
fürs komplette Projekt macht.
All das hier gehört nicht mir quasi.
Das gehört der Hausgemeinschaft.
Und das bedeutet, ich muss nicht mit der
Hausverwaltung in Verbindung setzen,
muss das mit denen abklären.
Also das ist richtig scheiße.
Also wirklich ein Problem, das den
kompletten Zeitplan für dieses Projekt,
für diese Wohnung auseinandernimmt.
Und weil diese Leitungen gehören
zum Haus, nicht zu meiner Wohnung.
Sie sind Gemeinschaftseigentum und gehören
quasi allen Eigentümern des
Hauses zu einem gewissen Anteil.
Das bedeutet, alle können gemeinsam
darüber entscheiden, wann diese
Leitungen wie erneuert werden.
Und es kann sich potenziell um Tage,
Wochen oder Monate handeln, dass dieses
Ding richtig auseinanderfliegt und das
komplette Haus voll mit Wasser läuft.
Was natürlich überhaupt nicht im Sinne
von irgendeinem der Eigentümer ist.
Deswegen kann der Hausverwalter in
bestimmten Fällen in akuten Fällen auch
selber entscheiden und man muss dann nicht
bis Dezember auf die nächste
Hauptversammlung warten, wo
darüber abgestimmt wird.
Der Hausverwalter, der im Übrigen
supernett und mega engagiert war, hat sich
nach 20:00 noch mit mir getroffen, um das
Problem anzuschauen und was
seine Einschätzung war.
Wie da jetzt weiter vorgegangen wird,
das erfahrt ihr später im Video.
Es ist sogar unheimlich viel in diesem
Projekt zu lernen, weil das ja eine meiner
Hauptmotivation für mich
und diesen Kanal ist.
Und deswegen freue ich mich umso mehr,
dass skillshare der Partner des heutigen Videos ist.
skillshare ist eine Onlineplattform, die es euch
ermöglicht, von überall aus übers Handy,
über den Br owser, über den Fernseher
und Chromecast sogar neue Skills zu lernen
oder bestehendes Geld zu verbessern.
Es gibt tausende Online Kurse zu
verschiedensten Themen, sodass
für jeden etwas dabei ist.
Von Kochen über Unternehmertum bis hin zu
3d Design ist wirklich alles dabei.
Das Angebot an deutschsprachigen Kursen
wächst stetig und es gibt einige coole
Skills zu lernen, wie zum Beispiel iPhone
Fotografie, die es euch ermöglicht, mit
eurem täglichen Begleiter bessere Fotos zu
machen und einfach das
Maximum rauszuholen.
Auch für mich ist das super wichtig, weil
ich natürlich unheimlich
viel mit dem Handy arbeite.
Alle meine Insta Fotos sind mit dem Handy
gemacht und auch in diesem Video habt ihr
schon einige Aufnahmen vom iPhone gesehen.
Aber auch alle englischsprachigen Kurse
sind deutsche Untertitel, wodurch ihr
beispielsweise die Möglichkeit habe,
Sketch up zu lernen, was das Programm ist,
mit dem ich die Wohnung designt
habe, in der ich hier gerade stehe.
Das Design ist zwar noch nicht umgesetzt,
aber ich habe es schon designt.
Das Beste ist aber Die ersten 1000 Leute
von euch kann es für 30 Tage komplett
kostenlos testen und ausprobieren.
Also seid schnell, klickt auf den ersten
in der Videobeschreibung und sichert
euch einen kostenlosen probe Monat.
Ich danke skillshare vielmals, dass Sie mich und das
gesamte Projekt unterstützen und dadurch
auch möglich machen und euch
viel Spaß weiter mit dem Video.
Außerdem gab es ein kleines Geschenk, was
wir in der Wand gefunden haben
Dynamit Nobel.
Das schauen wir uns jetzt mal gemeinsam an
Es steht 100 Kartuschen nur für Bolzen
Sets Werkzeug Kaliber 6,3 Millimeter, 1/4
Zoll starke Ladung einfach Patronenhülsen
bzw Patronen sind ja nicht nur Hülsen.
Ich denke, dass die irgendwie so ein
Hammer Werkzeug oder so reinkommen.
haha, kleines Geschenk.
Also die neuen Anschlüsse für Dusche, WC
und Waschbecken zusammengebastelt und
in den Wänden Platz für sie geschaffen.
Also alte Leitungen frei stemmen und raus.
Dann wurde mir gezeigt, wie man in
modernen Bauten frisch
Wasserleitungen verlegt.
Das Ganze ist ziemlich cool und
deutlich deutlich einfacher als früher.
Früher musste für alle Leitungen gelötet
werden, heute presst man sie, was deutlich
schneller, einfacher und komfortabler ist.
Also im Prinzip steckt man wirklich zwei
vorgefertigte Teile ineinander, hängt eine
Maschine dran, die dafür vorgesehen ist.
Die drückt diese Klemme zu
und wir sind fertig.
Neue Leitungen liegen überall, jetzt schon
im Bad, aber nur bis zum Ersten absperr
ventil also diesem Hahn, wo man in seiner
Wohnung für die Wohnung das Wasser
abdrehen kann, weil dahinter ist es dann
Gemeinschaftseigentum und
dahinter ist es am Rosten.
Der Hausverwalter klärt gerade mit den
Eigentümern über und unter
mir, wie es weitergehen soll.
Das Ding ist, die Situation
ist wirklich akut.
Also man kann nicht sagen, wann es da
kracht und wann das Wasser
dann wirklich da rausläuft.
Deswegen ist es im Sinne aller, dass die
Leitungen schnellstmöglich gemacht werden
und bei mir liegen sie jetzt eben frei.
Also im Prinzip spricht alles dafür, dass
wir jetzt schnellstmöglich eine Lösung
dafür finden und neue
Leitungen in die Wand ziehen.
Wir brauchen jetzt da eine Antwort, sonst
kann es erst mal nicht weitergehen.
Eine positive Sache hat das Ganze, aber
wir haben das jetzt hier offen und wir
sehen, dass hier am Abflussrohr eine
Muffe ist, an die wir dran gehen können.
Wir sehen gleichzeitig, dass hier die
Heizungsrohre laufen, was mit ziemlicher
Sicherheit bedeutet, dass die
Heizungsrohre hier irgendwo am Boden
hergehen, hier in die Heizung.
Das wiederum bedeutet, dass die
Heizungsrohre nicht unter dem
Estrich im  duschbereich sind.
Und das ist die perfekte Voraussetzung, um
möglichst Boden, tief oder zumindest sehr
nah dran zu kommen mit der Dusche Wanne,
was deutlich besser ist als gedacht,
weil ich jetzt schon fest davon
ausgegangen war, dass wir sieben acht
Zentimeter hoch müssen mit der Dusche.
Sieht jetzt aber deutlich besser.
Was ich hier gerade sehe,
ist unheimlich wichtig.
Ich habe gerade eben schon erklärt, warum.
Weil wer jetzt rausfinden konnten,
dass die Heizungsrohre nicht da sind.
Jeder Zentimeter, den wir hier rausholen,
hilft uns dabei, dass wir die Stufe
in der Dusche nicht hören müssen.
Das ist richtig geil und
viel besser als gedacht.
Wenn wir gerade mal
ein bisschen Rohr aus dem Bad freigelegt,
da geht nicht mehr so
besonders viel Wasser durch.
Manche Stellen gehen klar,
andere sind deutlich schlechter.
Also es ist schon sehr gut, dass wir
das wirklich einmal komplett machen.
Das hier war das frisch Wasser
für das Waschbecken.
Es hat noch funktioniert, aber es ist kein
Millimeter, also irgendwo
wahrscheinlich ein Millimeter.
Aber eigentlich ist hier dürfte
hier gar nix durchgehen.
So sehen vermutlich eure Leitungen aus,
wenn ihr in einem 70er Jahre Bau lebt, in
dem seit den 70er Jahren
nichts mehr gemacht wurde.
Und genau hier habe ich auch wieder
gemerkt, wie wichtig das war,
das Projekt größer anzugehen.
Also wirklich von Grund auf die Wohnung
umbauen, neu bauen zu wollen und
einmal alles zu kontrollieren.
Hätte ich jetzt für viel Geld neun Parkett
reingelegt, hätte die Wände neu gemacht,
hätte alles neu verputzen lassen, neu
spachteln lassen, neu streichen lassen und
in einem halben Jahr hätte es einen
Rohrbruch gegeben, dann hätte das eh alles
wieder aufgerissen werden müssen
und es wäre Wasser im Haus gewesen.
Also wirklich unheimlich wichtig, dass wir
uns dafür entschieden haben, dass von
Grund auf einmal richtig zu machen.
Nach dieser doch sehr anstrengenden Woche
nervenaufreibenden, etwas negativen Woche
für mich und das Projekt gab es dann
aber noch mal ein absolutes Highlight.
Mein Installateur des Vertrauens, Oliver
Marx, hat ein bisschen rum telefoniert und
andere Gewerke angerufen, mit denen
er gute Erfahrungen gemacht hat.
Und wir haben uns mit allen
gleichzeitig in der Wohnung getroffen.
Also wir haben jetzt einen Tischler,
der sich um alle Einbau Möbel kümmert.
Wir haben einen absoluten Experten im Bad,
der uns dabei hilft, das Bad noch
deutlich luxuriöser zu machen.
Das wird megageil und wir haben einen
Elektroinstallateur, der nicht nur Elektro
macht, sondern unsere
komplette Licht Planung gibt.
Also es wird jetzt richtig, richtig geil,
wenn wir denn irgendwann mal weitermachen
dürfen und die Wasserleitung repariert.
Wenn ihr das ganze nicht verpassen wollt,
wenn ihr sehen wollt wie die Einbau
Schränke reinkommen, wie im Bad
weitergeht, wie es mit der Haupt
wasserleitung weiter geht und soweiter.
Dann vergesst nicht den Kanals abonnieren.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche Sonntag zur
nächsten Folge wieder und hoffen, dass bis
dato unsere Wasser,
unsere Wasser, unsere Wohnung
nicht komplett unter Wasser steht.
Kuss kuss kuss